Schon in naher Zukunft wollen wir Menschen
den Mars besiedeln.
Doch dafür sind noch einige Herausforderungen
zu bewältigen: Wie sollen beispielsweise
lebenswichtige Rohstoffe wie Sauerstoff, Wasser
und Treibstoff auf den Roten Planeten gebracht
werden?
Unmöglich?
Jetzt tüftelt die NASA an einer wirklich
irren Lösung für genau dieses Problem: Autonome
Roboter sollen demnach aus lokalen Ressourcen,
nämlich der Mars-Erde, Wasser, Sauerstoff
und Treibstoff produzieren - Clixoom Science
& Fiction, hier gibt es täglich faszinierende
Sciencevideos, abonniert den Kanal.
Nur dann verpasst ihr nichts. herzlich willkommen!
Die Roboter sollen laut Plan der NASA schon
lange, bevor wir Menschen irgendwann einmal
auf dem Mars eintreffen, mit ihrer Arbeit
beginnen.
Als Basis für die Produktion der lebensnotwendigen
Ressourcen könnte Regolith genutzt werden,
ein lockeres Pulver aus verwittertem Vulkangestein.
Überall auf dem Mars verteilt.
Genauer gesagt besteht es aus sogenannten
Silikaten, die sich unter anderem aus Sauerstoff
und Silizium zusammensetzen.
Das Regolith befindet sich unter einer Eisenoxid-Schicht,
die die Oberfläche des Mars’ so rot erscheinen
lässt.
Doch der Abbau von Schichten dort ist alles
andere als einfach.
Die Gravitation auf dem Mars ja aber deutlich
niedriger als auf unserer Erde.
Sie beträgt nämlich nur 38 Prozent der Schwerkraft
unseres Heimatplaneten.
Und das würde die Arbeit der Schürfwerkzeuge
- wie beispielsweise das Drücken der Baggerschaufel
in den Boden - fast unmöglich machen.
Denn das Eigengewicht des Baggers wäre auf
dem Mars zu gering, um dieser Kraft entgegenzuwirken.
Zudem müssten die Roboter ja in Leichtbauweise
angefertigt werden, um so überhaupt auf den
Roten Planeten transportiert werden zu können.
Doch die NASA bat derzeit einen Prototypen,
der Hoffnung macht!
Eine Maschine namens “RASSOR”.
Das steht für “Regolith Advanced Surface
Systems Operations Robot”).
Seine Bauweise ist wirklich tricky: Er baut
die gewünschte Regolith-Schicht mit zwei
Schaufelrädern ab, wobei diese sich durch
gegenläufige Drehbewegungen neutralisieren.
Somit stellt die fehlende Schwerkraft kein
Problem mehr dar.
Durch die Arbeit des Roboters entsteht dabei
hinter ihm kein tiefes Loch, sondern eher
eine Art flacher Graben.
In einem nächsten Schritt soll RASSOR das
Material dann in eine Basis bringen, in der
es dann weiterverabeitet wird.
Auch diese Station soll nach Angaben der NASA
vollautomatisch laufen und das Regolith erhitzen.
Dabei entsteht zum einen Wasser, das gesammelt
wird und als Trinkwasser für mögliche Mars-Besiedler
dienen kann.
Doch mit dem gewonnen Wasser kann noch viel
mehr angestellt werden.
Durch Elektrolyse kann daraus nämlich sowohl
Wasser- als auch Sauerstoff gewonnen werden.
Und diese beiden Gase könnten dann wiederum
in einem weiteren Verarbeitungsschritt verflüssigt
werden.
Und somit als Treibstoff für Raketentriebwerke
dienen - wow!
Doch die NASA hat eine andere Idee: Sie will
flüssigen Wasserstoff dann durch Kombination
mit Kohlenstoff zu Methan umwandeln, das dann
auch als Treibstoff genutzt werden kann.
Und damit zurück zum Regolith: Durch das
Erhitzen entsteht neben dem Wasser außerdem
ein staubtrockenes Abfallprodukt.
Dieses soll von den Robotern entsorgt werden
und als Ausgangsprodukt für den Bau von Häusern
und Straßen dienen.
Diese sollen durch 3D-Druck entstehen.
Hammer!
Diese Anlage könnte also einige Jahre, bevor
die erste Besatzungs-Mission den Mars erreicht,
ihre Arbeit beginnen und somit systematisch
alle notwendigen Vorräte für eine erfolgreiche
Mission bereitstellen.
Und das ist alles viel mehr als reine Science-Fiction:
Verschiedene Ingenieur-Teams der NASA sind
bereits dabei, diese Vision zur Realität
werden zu lassen..
Laut NASA soll das Ganze schon in naher Zukunft
verschiedene Testläufe absolvieren - zunächst
auf der Erde, und dann auf dem Mond.
Als großes Finale soll die Idee dann irgendwann
auf dem Mars selbst realisiert werden.
Wenn es es Neuigkeiten dazu gibt, dann erfahrt
ihr es natürlich hier und zuerst auf WhatsApp.
Dafür hier klicken und den Newsletter abonnieren.
Ansonsten: Bids dann, bleibt dran!